but in the sacrifice actually carried
out consciousness having nullified the
action as its own doing and also in
principle obtain relief from its misery
that its relief has been obtained in
principle is however the action of the
other extreme of the syllogism which is
the essence possessed of intrinsic being
but the sacrifice made by the
unessential extreme was at the same time
not a one-sided action but contained
within itself the action of the other
for the surrender of one's will is only
from one aspect negative in principle
however in itself it is at the same time
positive that is the positing of will is
the will of another and specifically it
will not as a particular but as a
universal will this positive meaning of
the negatively positive particular will
is taken by this consciousness to be the
will of the other extreme the will which
precisely because it is in other for
consciousness becomes actual for it not
through the unhappy consciousness itself
but through a third the mediator is
counselor hence for consciousness its
will does indeed become Universal it
essential will but consciousness itself
does not take itself to be this
essential will the surrender of its own
will as a particular will is not taken
by it to be in principle the positive
aspect of universal will similarly it's
giving up of possessions and enjoyment
has only the same negative meaning and
the universal which thereby comes to be
for it is not regarded as its own doing
this is unity of objectivity and being
for self which lies in the notion of
action and which therefore becomes for
consciousness essence and object this
unity is not the principle of its action
and so too it does not become an object
for consciousness directly and through
itself rather it lets the mediating
minister express this certainty a
certainty which is itself still
incomplete that is misery is only in
principle the reverse that is that it's
action brings it only in principle the
self-satisfaction or blessed enjoyment
that is pitiable action
who is only in principle the reverse
that is an absolute action that in
principle action is really is only
really action loaded as the action of a
particular individual but for itself
action and its own actual doing remain
pitiable its enjoyment remains pain and
the overcoming of these in a positive
sense remains a beyond but in this
object in which it finds that its own
action of being as being that of this
particular consciousness are being an
action in themselves their hands are
risen for consciousness the idea of
reason of the certainty that in its
particular individuality it has being
absolutely in itself or is all reality
we have finally arrived at paragraph 230
the last paragraph of this entire
section of the unhappy consciousness of
the stoicism skepticism of the unhappy
consciousness and of the
self-consciousness section in general so
we're passing a very important milestone
this is a again like all the previous
last paragraph that a moment of
transition where we're going to move
into the very beginning of a new
dialectic of reason this one's going to
be pretty fast a lot more to say about
that in a bit and Hegel ends it on a
very long passage which we won't be able
to all fit on the board at this point
I'll have to do a little bit of erasure
and put in some other stuff up let's
let's plow our way through it so he says
that again now what we've got is is the
sort of two sided thing with the the
individual unhappy consciousness on this
side and both the mediator and the
unchangeable on this side as the
essential as opposed to the unessential
a sacrifice and opt for rowing boats are
made sacrifices and offering on tues is
taking place it's not just an offering
of something extrinsic it's an offering
of the very being the very activities
the very functions of the individual
consciousness so something really
important is taking place here something
transformative he goes on an attorney
says in the sacrifice carried out of
consciousness having nullify the action
as its own doing han is also in
principle and that in principle here is
on Zeke the reason that I put it there
that put the German there is because
there's another on Zeke that shows up
very soon that's being translated a
little bit differently in this Miller
translation I want to call your
attention to
in principle the the individual
consciousness has obtained relief from
its misery it's no longer the unhappy
consciousness Anzhi in itself but is it
yet in and for itself not yet that still
has to be worked out so there's a you
might say a realization that has taken
place that isn't fully actualized that
still has to be drawn out nichoza
nominee says that is relief he has been
obtained in principle is however the
action of the other extreme of the
syllogism of shrews right the other
extreme has the unchangeable so it's
still being viewed as the the action of
the other were to see that happened to
bodie allottees here he says he is the
essence possessed of intrinsic be on
Zeke's iana right so in a certain sense
the the in itself isn't entirely on the
side of the individual consciousness
it's still a little bit mistaken about
the priority of what's going on and he
goes ahead and he says sacrifice made by
the unessential extreme was at the same
time not a one-sided action there is a
kind of reciprocal movement going on
back and forth here so how does this
work Hagel's going to talk in terms of
two things at this point in terms of
will and in terms of enjoyment and
that's going to lead us to action
actually I mean action involves both of
these things so he says the this once
this not one-sided action contained
within itself the action of the other
and at first it looks like the action on
the or the initiative on the side of the
other predates you might say whether
temporarily or logically what's
happening on this
but really it's this this side
individual who is making all of this
happen where the agency is really
occurring he says the surrender of one's
will is only in one aspect negative so
surrendering ones will it first seems to
be like giving something up right but as
we've seen there is a willing involved
in the very surrender of one's will the
fact that one can give it over is a
choice that that's done from will so
it's not as if the will is totally you
know stripped away from somebody they
are carrying out that willing giving it
over so any gear he talks in slightly
different terms he says then it's in
principle or however we're get itself
right on Zeke again it is at the same
time positive how well it's the positive
of will as the will of another so it's
positive it's setting forth it's putting
out there you could say this whole idea
of will it's not just that it's
retaining for itself a little bit of
willing it is actually making it
possible for what it will is being
surrendered to to be a destination for
its will another will when you surrender
your will you don't just surrender it
out there you know to the universe to
the cosmos no you surrender it to
something else that has a will if you're
going to give over your your own you
know autonomy of making judgments for
yourself to a mediator you're doing that
precisely because that mediator himself
or herself is assumed to be able to make
judgments right so what happens here is
there's a positive of will will as
universal this is something that we're
going to play out quite a bit in the
reason section and also in the spirit
section
to come but we're seeing just the very
beginnings of it right here I'm smiling
because this is something really
interesting that that's that's happening
and I know what's going up down the line
so you says if the positive will is the
will of another and specifically it will
that is a particular not ins just sit in
my will or that will or but as universal
will as carrying a kind of rightness or
normativity to it it only makes sense to
give your will over to the mediator as a
rational being if you think that the
mediator has actually got things better
if the mediator has a closer
relationship than you do with what is
unchangeable what is essential what has
intrinsic being when you're doing that
you're treating the mediator is if the
mediator is the expression of a
universal will so it says here we go
this positive meaning of the negatively
positive particular will the negatively
positive particularly wills one's own
will is taken by this consciousness to
be the will of the other extreme the
will which precisely because it is
another for consciousness becomes actual
for it not through the unhappy
consciousness itself but through a third
the mediator it's hard to the you know
wrap one's head around the will of the
divine or something like that it's
easier to do so in terms of the will of
something that is a mediator that you
can actually you know connect with so
you says for consciousness it will does
indeed become Universal in a central
will but consciousness itself does not
take itself to be this exceptional look
what well consciousness has as we've
seen over and over again fail to grasp
that all of this is it's up all of this
is
consciousness all right and it's treated
consciousness as if its just its own
individual contingent unessential almost
next to nothing exists its bare
existence but that's really a mistake
that it has to make and in doing so I'm
working through it comes to know itself
as being involved in this entire process
we can go a little bit further and
another similar sort of dynamic takes
place he says the surrender okay here we
go giving up a possessions and enjoyment
has only the same negative meaning on
the universal which there but I comes to
be four so there's a universal generated
in this as well then Universal has not
taken to be its own being why not you
know what would the universal be in this
case we might think of the totality of
enjoyment and possessions right that the
individual only has a little bit of and
they can contribute to they enjoy a
little bit but really again all of this
all of this is consciousness there's a
positive it's taking place there there's
a doing that is that is understood to be
on the part of the other of a part of
the unchangeable of a part of the
mediator on the part of that which
really matters as opposed to oneself
that the really matter doesn't really
have beings really have you know a
meaningful important existence and yet
this is where the action is happening
now action is a very important term
that's coming up here and we need to
erase a little bit of this and take up
the rest of the paragraph once we filled
out the board a bit more all right so I
cleared us a bit of room
for the rest of what Hagel's talking
about here I'm going to put a little bit
more on the board as we go through this
but let's take up now at this idea or as
he's saying here the notion the degree
of the concept of action and why is
Hagel focusing at the end of this
section on action rather than on say
thinking or cognition well because for
Hegel action is going to be one of the
central categories this often gets left
out when people are are talking about
the dialectic and and the process it
tends to become very intellectualized
right and Hagel is saying no where
things really do happen is where ideas
become action where they become
effective very early right they become
they become something that's actual
something that does things within the
world within a person's life within
consciousness itself and so you know
thinking itself is an action it's not
the case that action is merely the after
effect of thought so he goes on and I've
got here in the center not only the
mediator but all this stuff that he's
saying about the notion of action he
says then what happens is that we're
going back to this you know giving up
the possessions of the Willises this
unity of objectivity and being for self
right gay and Stanley k being being
objective being in the form of objects
and being for self having a kind of
reflexive relation to the self being
able to figure 2 to the self that is in
the concept the living unity of what
action involves there's a side of
determining oneself involved in acting
and being able to take a stance upon
oneself form ideas about where one is
going
you know turn oneself in the direction
that one wishes and also one treats
oneself as an object it's not just a
matter of acting upon other objects it's
also using one's own faculties one's own
body one's own resources as the object
right so that's one side of it any sense
that here we go this is unity of
objectivity of being for itself which
relies the notion of action in which
therefore becomes for consciousness
essence vaison and object gagan sean
right for consciousness consciousness
the question is going to be what where
is consciousness in this is it over here
is that here is over here is it through
the entire thing as we know very well it
is so it becomes therefore for
consciousness essence an object he says
this unity is not the principle of its
action whose action a particular
individual this is what action you might
say ought to be instead for the
particular individual at this stage it's
still is he's going to call it
impoverish arabica action right pitiable
is a nice translation something that is
not fully what it ought to be so he says
you know it's not the principle of its
action and so into does not become an
object for consciousness directly and
through itself why not well because his
action was in part to sacrifice so many
things to the mediator to the the
essential to whatever lay beyond and
even you know in thinking there was that
sacrifice taking place right is that
really going to be the case though well
here's where we see something really a
quick striking occurring he says look at
the particular individual let's the
mediating minister express this
I put a certainty in with a question
mark after it because Hagel is going to
call that certainty into question from
the perspective of the particular
individual the grass is greener on the
other side ontologically or in terms of
action right the mediator is the one
who's really got this all together and
is able to act and you know in such a
way that this this is this really the
case but he says um lets the mediating
minister express this certainty a
certainty which is itself incomplete a
certainty of what that is misery it's
unhappiness it's one look right the
unhappy consciousness is unhappy it is
only in principle Ozzy the reverse that
it's action brings it only in principle
self-satisfaction or blessed enjoyment
the question here is now lated of
certainty being called into question but
also satisfaction where is satisfaction
occurring who is enjoying satisfaction
things were being exchanged
consciousness in the form of the
particular individual is divesting
itself is actually acting an awful lot
of doing a lot on its side in a lot of
different models as we've seen in terms
of its willing its desire in terms of
its action itself it's if work its labor
in terms of its enjoyment or consumption
in terms of giving thanks all the agency
seems to be coming from the side of the
particular individual and yet where is
the satisfaction where is the enjoyment
really taking place is it the universal
unchangeable list that's engaging in
that as we've seen projected so many
times now throughout the course of this
or do we have to ascend to to a higher
dialectical level he goes on and he says
it's pitiable action its ear Malika TURN
RIGHT is only in principle the reverse
that is what an absolute action
absolutely action would be happening on
the side of the universal and the
unchanged
but here Hagel is going to point out to
us a little paradox or a problem with
talking about absolute action and saying
oh this is impoverished by comparison
what's the problem well it's this in
principle action is only really action
when it is the action of a particular
individual let me read that again in
principle action is really only action
when is the action of a particular
individual this is all you get
ontological e whatever is happening over
here is really happening because of this
or because of a sum of individual
actions or a competent or some sort of
you know effect of many many individuals
doing something mediated through the
media but even the action of the
mediator is ultimately in some sense
coming from the particular individual
this is a reversal of perspective that's
taking place the universal the
unchangeable was seen as you know that
which is providing everything that's why
you have to be grateful to for giving
you the faculties that you have and yet
action really only occurs at the level
of individuals the idea that sounds very
anti a Galia doesn't the idea in and of
itself doesn't do anything it just sits
there and where does it sit there maybe
in a book maybe in somebody's head maybe
as a little blurb bullet point in
somebody's plan it's only one in
particular individuals act that any of
this really matters so if this does seem
to matter it is this doesn't seem to
matter even more since it's the meteor
it's because of all these particular
individuals who have indeed than an ting
this is where idealism
is really about the world of particulars
not just a mind out there thinking
itself but hey let's try to be as
realistic as possible so he goes on and
he sets here we go action is really only
action when is the action of a
particular individual but the individual
doesn't realize that yet for itself
action and its own actual doing remain
pitiable why he hasn't yet grasped all
of this its enjoyment remains pain the
overcoming of these in a positive sense
remains a Fiat what is it beyond what's
what's happening over here what's going
on at the mediator that the particular
individual doesn't get grasp what's
happening with the thing that's being
mediated or the person or whatever the
force of the mediator medians so he goes
on in this object in which it finds that
its own action and peeing as being of
this particular consciousness are being
an action in themselves we have be a
action of the particular individual and
then we have DEA and action yes
themselves
these are all connected the these are
all coming out of this he says there is
arisen for consciousness the idea of
reason on the certainty that in its
particular individuality it has it it
has being absolutely in itself where is
all reality now he is saying that this
is the was very important here idea of
reason he's not saying that this is the
reality of fully developed reason and he
means something more than just you know
the rational faculty he means
rationality per se but so far what's
coming onto the scene is not reason
itself in its fully developed deployed
state it's the beginning the glimmerings
of this but the individual now has
arrived at the point where the
individual at least the one who has
advanced to this stage can say I get all
of this is really for me all of this is
really an extension of what's going on
for me through the social process in
communication however we want to make
sense of it it's not a purely
solipsistic understanding because this
is socially mediated but each individual
who is getting this can say I have the
potential to understand from the
perspective not only of my particular
being in my particular action but being
an action in themselves what I want to
close with here is by stressing
something that I had mentioned a little
bit earlier on but i think is very
important it was worth stressing over
and over again hail takes his position
here not just in terms of being not just
in terms of thoughts not just in turn
terms of you know theoretical philosophy
but in terms of action in terms of doing
in terms of work in terms of the things
that human beings actually engage in
because we have the faculties to do so
this is not a philosophy that is you
know detached from from the world
although sometimes Hagel's been
interpreted in such a way right angle
sometimes says things that give rise to
that point of view but here we see the
Galleon system in its greatest dynamic
quality in its focus on action this is
going to be very important as we go
through the section to come reason it's
not just speculative or theoretical
reason that Hagel is going to be talking
about us developing and charting that up
it's going to be practical reason and
practical reason is not going to be
something totally cut off from or
detached from but you might say it
actually undergirds theoretical reason
I'll leave you with that thought and we
finally arrived at the end of this
section